[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT TAI: Welcome everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Matt Tai.
I'm a product manager with
Google Cloud Platform.
And today I'd like
to talk to you
about accelerating marketing
insight with Google Cloud.
So I do want to level
set everyone, likely need
to run your business with
facts and not feelings.
To do that, everyone
knows you have
data you need to get insights
from, to ultimately make money.
I mean, that's why
we're all here.
So as a business leader, what
are some things I need to do?
I want to get a single
view of my business.
I want to invest in my most
promising opportunities.
And I want to
understand my customer.
So wouldn't it be great if I can
get a dashboard on my business,
understand how all my different
market segments were doing,
how my advertisements
are performing
across all the different
channels I was spending money
across?
Hello.
Invest in the most
promising opportunities.
If you're in the
advertising space,
there's been an old joke.
I know 50% of my
ad spend is wasted.
I just don't know which 50%.
So how do you identify
which 50% is doing well,
which one's not doing well?
And finally, how do you
understand your customer?
How do you understand and
profile your ideal customer?
How do you improve the
targeting for that.
And so you want to find--
sorry.
I'm just going to skip this.
So these are the
things you want to do,
but these are the
challenges I face.
So data lives in silos.
If you're advertising
with us on Google,
you already know that, say,
on AdWords or DoubleClick, DFP
or YouTube, these are
all individual silos
you need to connect to
and pull into one place
to get visibility
into your customer.
Now that's just for marketing.
What about your own
first party data?
What about your customers,
your CRM data, purchasing,
invoicing?
How do you get that
all into one place?
It's really hard to get
insight in your customer
if you can't even get
everything in a single place
to look at it.
And earlier I
said, well you have
to make a decision
on identifying
which 50% is performing poorly
or which one is doing well.
Well in the marketing space,
there's 3,000 tools for you
to choose from.
So even before you decide
which 50% is good or bad,
you need to make a decision as
to which tools you want to use
to help solve that problem.
In terms of understanding
your customer,
we spoke with a large bank,
asked them this question.
That was their answer.
How much data, how
much customer data
do I use in my
advertising tools?
None, I can't link
the data sets.
So, what do you want
to spend your time on?
Do you want to be a business
owner or a data plumber?
Do you want to spend your
time running your business
or moving all the
data into one place?
Really, it shouldn't
be this hard.
And this is how Cloud
would like to help.
Earlier today we announced the
BigQuery Data Transfer Service.
What it is is a data
movement service
from our largest
advertising platforms
into BigQuery on a
scheduled managed basis.
If you're a customer of AdWords,
DoubleClick, Bid or Campaign
Manager, DoubleClick for
Publishers or YouTube,
today you can have your
analysts move data into BigQuery
without having any
development effort required.
Now BigQuery is just where
you load all your data.
That's great in
isolation, but hey,
what if you want to get your
web traffic data in there?
What if you want to get your
mobile traffic in there?
Well Google Analytics
360 customers
also have direct
connectivity to BigQuery.
And they will export their data
to BigQuery for you as well.
And finally, if you're
a CMO or a marketer,
you need to do more than
just Google properties.
So how do you get data from
Salesforce, Facebook, Twitter,
Marketo, MailChimp, or
Eloqua into BigQuery?
We have an ecosystem
of partners for you
to work with to set
up that automated data
movement into BigQuery.
So we've identified
three steps to insight.
The first step is collecting
all the data in one place.
With the BigQuery
Data Transfer Service,
you can get AdWords,
DoubleClick for Publishers,
DoubleClick Bid and
Campaign Manager,
and YouTube into BigQuery.
With Google Analytics, they
have direct connectivity
into BigQuery as well.
And for the non-Google
data sources
that aren't mentioned
here, you can
work with our partners such
as Informatica, Segment,
and Funnel to get your
Salesforce data, Facebook,
Marketo into BigQuery as well.
The second step is
then figuring out
how to make sense of it all.
So once you get the data into
BigQuery, it's pretty raw.
For those of you who are
advertising professionals,
you know that you have
to inject your custom
IDs into, say, DoubleClick,
shows up as other data.
How do you extract
that from those strings
and make use of it?
Also earlier today we
announced a product
called Cloud Dataprep, which
is a visual ETL tool that
lets you clean up
that data, again,
without having to
do any programming.
So your analyst can
then use Cloud Dataprep
to clean up that data,
extract those custom user IDs,
and dump that into BigQuery.
If you have a data
engineering team,
we have Apache Beam
via Cloud Dataflow.
If you want to do something
more sophisticated than just
a simple extraction,
you can use Dataflow
to pull the raw
data from BigQuery
and then dump it back in there,
cleansed and ready to go.
And the third piece is the
analysis and visualization
piece.
So what I want to show here
is that BigQuery is not
its own island.
You can of course use SQL to
analyze the data in place.
But we also support
exports to Excel.
You can also pull data
from Google Sheets.
And for the technical
numbers of the audience,
we do have JDBC and ODBC
connectivity as well.
On top of that,
Dataprep does work
with a lot of existing
visualization partners listed
here.
Tableau, Looker, Google Data
Studio, among many others,
work with BigQuery
out of the box.
We're doing all of this
to accelerate your time
to insight.
So next I'd like to hand the
mic over to a few customers
that we've invited over.
And we'll have
Mercedes-Benz USA come up,
as well as their agency,
SapientRazorfish.
Then we'll transition
over to Zenith.
And we will have a fireside chat
after that with "The New York
Times" and Hearst.
MATTHEW GRANISH: Thank you Matt.
Good afternoon.
I'm Matthew Granish
from Mercedes-Benz USA.
And it's a real
pleasure and privilege
to be speaking with
all of you today.
I think most of you are
a lot smarter than I am.
And I'm the business guy.
I'm not the programmer.
So it's been really cool to
see the breakout sessions
and see how the
mechanics behind all the
questions that I ask of our data
scientists and engineers, what
actually makes that possible.
So it's really cool to be here.
So I'll talk about
what we're doing.
So our data, as you can
imagine like most clients,
we're getting data from all
kinds of different places--
from our websites, from our
media, from our dealerships,
from after-sales.
I mean, it just goes on and on.
So like Matt was saying,
most of it is in silos.
So we're trying to
bring all that together.
So what we've noticed is a
lot of the companies that
are really doing
well are working
on kind of like a data
as a platform space.
So in order to do
that, our vision is
to try to be at the
intersection of,
not only are we superior
technology-wise,
but we can be flexible.
We can be agile.
We can be creative.
We can let the data
power the decisions
that need to be made
to determine what
marketing strategies
we use instead of just
kind of sticking our
thumb up in the air
and hoping that we're
targeting the right people
and using the right message,
and then connecting it
from all the departments
within the M-B USA.
So is what we're doing
helping our vans department?
Is what we're doing helping
our after-sales department,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then so some growth
opportunities for us
by having this connected data--
I mean, it's really about being
a customer-centric company.
Matt mentioned having a
complete view of your business.
So for us it's really about
having a complete view
of your customer.
So it's getting away
from that aggregate data
at the broad level,
demo level, to what
is Matthew Granish doing?
Because the way I
buy a car is probably
going to be different than the
way the next guy buys a car.
And so we have KPI buckets
and intuition that tells us
that you start here and you
do this and you end up there.
But in reality, everybody
does it differently.
So we really need
to use these things
to generate internal
efficiencies
so we can track all of this.
And so this is just kind of
reinforcing that, putting
the customer first.
And so this is kind
of like the path
that you could say where
most companies are probably
progressing.
So we start off with a very
simple, basic, retroactive look
at what we did.
And then we're trying
to build the systems
through the
interconnectivity that we
use the cloud for to get
those real time optimizations
and to identify what are the
things that the people who
are converting doing,
and how is that
different than the
people who are not
converting so we can target the
converters more efficiently?
So as we get towards
the highest bar,
the customer centricity,
obviously there's
a lot of data that
has to be processed,
and very quickly, to
make all that happen.
So you'll hear from
our data scientists
on why the Google
platform works so well.
For me, it just works really
well because it's fast.
So we don't have a
petabyte of data yet.
But if you saw that
example at 12:00,
they analyzed a petabyte of data
in two minutes or something,
almost three minutes.
So if they can do
that in three minutes,
then ours is going to
be a walk in the park.
So that's why I'm
really happy is
they're able to answer the
questions that I have very
quickly and I don't
have to wait days
to get the information
that I need
to inform marketing choices.
So just some reasons
why GCP works--
it's quick, it costs
less, and there's not
a big implementation time.
Most of our systems
are already using
a Google product of some
sort, so the integration
was very easy for us.
And now I'll bring up Evan
Rowe, the science director,
to get more into
the nitty-gritty.
[APPLAUSE]
EVAN ROWE: Thank you.
So Matt talked a little
bit about creating
this integrated
view of the customer
and how that's going to
be a big part of driving
engagement with the brand.
And we see that across the board
for marketing services-- so
across the digital
properties, across CRM
and direct marketing,
across media, and then
really across the board for
things like understanding
lifetime value and even
driving accountability
through ROI analyzes.
And of course this isn't
always that simple, right?
There are a lot of
challenges that we're
going to face to make
this vision come to life.
And one of the
biggest challenges
is, there's a really, really
big ecosystem of data here.
So we have all this social and
media data, which as you know,
it's massive.
We also have all of
these digital properties,
all of these apps.
We have CRM and loyalty systems.
And then we have,
as Matt mentioned,
this sort of distributed
dealer network
that all comes
with its own data.
And of course, all of these
have their own platforms
and systems and tools
for us to kind of wrestle
with to bring this together.
And coordinating all of that
is, I think, Pretty, much
a universal challenge.
I mean obviously the
automotive industry
has its eccentricities.
But of course I think
every marketer really
sees this landscape and
they say, how can we create
a single view of the customer?
And to talk a little bit more
about the actual scale here--
so while I think that Mercedes--
it should be easy
to make this choice.
It's a superior product and
it should be an easy decision.
But the car buying experience,
it's a long consideration
cycle, right?
It's a big decision.
There's a lot of
planning and research
that goes into
making that decision.
And so over these sort of
months long decision process,
we have so many interactions
and touch points.
So think about the millions of
customers, all the platforms we
were just talking
about, and look
at that over three to six
months while someone is really
making this decision.
We're talking about
billions upon billions
of individual interactions.
And we can't really
make sense of those
without using
statistical models.
And so one of the
things that we do
is we have to use models
to kind of systematically
help us determine who the right
people are to target, what
decisions we should be making.
And so that comes
with its own challenge
because then it takes time and
resources to develop, build,
test the models.
And that process doesn't
always lend itself
to your more real time use cases
like serving digital media.
And on top of this, so there's
this initial Google Cloud
for Marketers rollout
that happened last fall.
And they talked about
some of the benefits
and some of what they
envision for this platform.
And it talked about collecting,
analyzing, visualizing,
and iterating on data.
And I think that's a
very, very good way
to position the value
of this for marketers.
But for the future
marketing collateral
for Cloud for Marketers,
we're adding one more.
We're going to add activate,
because we also see
this as an activation platform.
And if you're going to create
an ecosystem where you integrate
all of your customer
data across the board,
I think there are a lot
of additional use cases
that you can activate outside
of just the sort of time
to insight and driving
efficiencies in the analytics
process.
And so just sort of an
overview of our challenges
and how we're addressing
them with the cloud.
As far as data collection goes,
we have all these platforms.
But actually a lot of
them, as Matt mentioned,
are already on Google platforms.
And so we were really able to
speed up the data collection
process by taking
advantage of that.
As far as analysis
goes, we were kind
of building an EDW within
BigQuery, which as we know
is very fast at produced
the querying time.
And also, we don't have any
operational concerns anymore.
As far as visualization
goes, a lot of our use case
is actually--
we were using Google
Data Studio actually
as a dashboarding tool,
which actually it's
met most of our needs so far.
And obviously we can integrate
with additional platforms
if we need to.
And as far as iteration
goes, all of that time
we were talking about that
goes into developing models,
we're able to automate
them now in the cloud.
And that's really
speeding up that process.
And then as far as
activation goes,
we also have all
of these use cases
around personalization
for the site and for CRM,
and then also things
like audience management
for media, which we see as a
really, really big opportunity
here.
So we really see a lot of
extensibility to this platform
and a lot of potential use
cases that we can apply it to.
And with that I'm
going to hand it off
to Jeremy, who's going to talk
through our actual architecture
and our experience so far
working with Google Cloud.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY TERUYA: Hello.
I'm Jeremy.
I'm associate director
here at SapientRazorfish.
So I'm going to walk through
some of the actual architecture
of how this was accomplished.
So this is essentially our
basic architecture right now.
As Evan mentioned, there's a
lot of disparate data sources
that we collect.
So these are just a few
examples right now--
DoubleClick, Google
Analytics 360, YouTube,
Kenshoo with paid
search, even some stuff
from MBIT for CRM
for after-sales,
dealership relationships.
So kind of the
basic walkthrough.
And I should probably
put icons there labeling
what each of these are.
So if you're unfamiliar with
the actual Google products,
this may not be that beneficial.
But from reading
left to right, it's
essentially we do use a
combination of Dataflow
and the connectors or
Data Transfer Service
that Matt Tai mentioned was
announced earlier today.
We load, during the
daily ETL process,
Google Cloud Storage backups
in case anything goes awry.
That's going down.
And then reading to the
right, BigQuery obviously
is our enterprise data
warehouse solution.
Visualization through
Google Data Studio
and a mix of Tableau,
just depending
on what our individual
stakeholders need.
And then moving more toward
the automation and activation
portion now, Evan
had mentioned that we
use a lot of more modeling
purposes and statistical means
to make sense of all
of this information.
So we've been playing
around with Data Lab
over the course over the
last three to six months.
But a lot of our
major development work
is done on Jupyter
as a platform.
And we use Dataproc
as a way to automate
a lot of the modeling code.
So that's on the far right.
So a lot of the modeling
that's iterated on
is either reingested
back into BigQuery
as a way to validate and also
to monitor as a performance
mechanism, but also we
use specific and custom
integrations with
different platforms
to push information out.
So the activation portion
that Evan was talking about
is a really, really important
component to our success.
So this entire solution
architecture right now
has officially been registered
as a partner solution
within Google.
So this is essentially how
we've laid it out for Mercedes.
And so kind of
the reasons why we
went through this
whole migration
process-- so we
were on AWS before.
I don't really need to
spend a whole lot of time.
I'm sure everyone in here has
seen all the demonstrations
over the course of the last
day as well as potentially
in the past.
BigQuery is very fast.
This is not as impressive
as the petabyte example
that they had shown at
the 12 o'clock session,
but essentially what
we found is the speed
is really not determining how
many questions we ask anymore.
I could go run a query across
gigabytes and gigabytes of data
or terabytes of data and
maybe go get a coffee
or go to a meeting
and when I come back,
it may or may not be done.
I don't really have to
worry about that anymore.
I can kind of iterate
on my questions and all
of the questions from
Mercedes and get them back
in a timely manner.
Also mitigating the
loss of productivity
due to human error--
so a lot of times
as our analysts
are running queries
against other solutions--
you write your code.
You execute it.
You wait a good amount of
time and it comes out wrong.
I can mitigate that loss
because it's very, very fast
and I don't have to worry
about, oh crap, I just
messed up and wasted two hours.
So this is essentially a basis.
So we know BigQuery
was fast and we
know it was a
great architecture,
but we already had the
system set up in AWS.
So really, was the
juice worth the squeeze
in terms of doing this
whole migration process?
One of the big hangups
for us was we've
architected a lot of custom
integrations into Redshift.
Do we want to repeat that again?
So with the connectors or Data
Transfer Service right now,
as Matt mentioned,
Mercedes is a brand
that has a lot of
products on Google.
So leveraging the connectors was
a very, very simple solution.
So this is kind of like
a one week process for--
I believe this was
DoubleClick at the time.
So for engineers,
this may or may not
be very similar to the processes
that you guys have architected
in the past of getting
that data transfer files
into a suitable SQL warehouse.
But essentially
the gist of it is,
we've gone from
debugging Spark code
and making sure that the
scripts are automating correctly
on an ETL process on
a daily fashion to,
can you or can you
not fill out a form?
It's very, very simple to set
up the data transfer process.
You literally open it up.
You type in your network IDs.
You set a cadence,
and then it just goes.
And it's very fast.
So we have enterprise
data warehouse.
It's very, very fast.
BigQuery, the connectors sped
up the infrastructure setup
as well.
So essentially we
reduce our delivery time
for performance reporting or
analysis from any questions
that Mercedes had by around 60%.
So we clear the way for getting
a lot of the base questions
down that they have, and as well
as increasing sophistication
of the questions that they
would like to ask because now we
have a lot more time.
And this is like a little quote
from the last analytics trend
report from Deloitte last year.
"So big data and traditional
analytics are emerging.
So it's really,
really getting harder
to distinguish the two
because the asks are
getting more sophisticated."
So setting up a
platform like this
has allowed us to
scale our ability
to answer those questions in
a very, very timely manner.
Increasing the time for
exploratory analysis
for Mercedes, as well as
has added benefit for us
at SapientRazorfish is,
essentially, you now
have this great architecture.
Potentially there are other
great analytic storytellers
or great data analysts or
traditional business analysts
who may want to get
their hands on this
and sort of do a cross-train
against your department.
For us at least it's been
a very, very great benefit.
A lot of people have sort
of flocked over to us
and sort of, we do
little training sessions
here and there.
So net-net, cost
times scale all have
improved over the
course of our migration.
80% reduction in startup
costs, not just time and money.
BigQuery's very fast,
answer more questions
that you need answered,
increase your allocation
to generate insight
as well as scale.
So scale was the
biggest thing for us.
As the questions become
more and more complex,
we need bigger horsepower.
So while sometimes we just
use a general four core
whatever BigQuery
has, we sometimes
scale it up in
Dataproc as needed.
And with that, I'll
hand it back to Matt.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: Next up
I'd like to introduce
Ian Liddicoat from Zenith.
IAN LIDDICOAT: Thank you sit.
Good afternoon everyone.
So Ian, head of
data and technology
and analytics at Zenith.
I'm a data scientist and
I'm still taking the drugs.
Just to orientate
our organization,
Zenith is part of Publicis,
the marketing services company,
second largest in the world.
You just heard from Razorfish,
which is part of Sapient.
So we are brothers and
sisters you might say.
You'll see in the next slide
that digital and the use
of technology is having a
huge impact on our business.
And it's really for
this reason that we
see Google, and
particularly the cloud,
as a very significant
partner to us going forward.
And you can see the scale of
the evolution in our business
between 2009 and 2015.
And it's definitely connected
consumers, driving our clients,
driving our clients for
increased personalization,
that then in turn
drives our business.
And I don't see that
trend changing at all.
So Google is a very
important partner to us.
And I see them as--
I distinguish Google,
in particular,
as a partner rather than
a software supplier.
And we are heavy users of their
technology, the cloud included.
And there's probably many
people in this audience
that would have
traditionally been AWS users.
And we are no different.
But we didn't really
have any interest
in just switching cloud
platforms if there
wasn't a long term benefit.
And I certainly see Google
as the long term partner,
particular in the
use case I'm going
to talk to you about today.
Particularly as a
media agency, we
are heavy users of the
DoubleClick platform,
and have spent many years
encouraging many of our biggest
global clients to switch to
an integrated Google ad tech
stack, for a lot of reasons.
And it's enabled us to do
some of the things I'm going
to talk about in a second.
So what's our particular
use case for the cloud?
Well it actually involves
artificial intelligence,
which you might not expect to
see from a traditional media
agency.
But it's because we
started to reimagine
what the digital media agency
is going to be in the future.
Now what we're doing here is
taking very, very granular
cookie level data
from the ad server,
fusing that with first party
data from all our clients,
and then applying
a set of machine
learning algorithms
to all of that data
to determine what is it
that's driving the conversion,
or whatever the
given KPI might be.
But then in a world first,
we've taken that machine
learning result and we've
pushed it back to DoubleClick.
Now that's never been done.
Now the reason we're doing
that is not because it's clever
and it's technically difficult
to achieve, which it is.
It's because we really want
to think about the automated
digital media agency
of the future that's
closed loop and
highly automated.
And that's exactly what
you're seeing here.
And this process started nearly
two years ago with a Aviva
as the founding client.
And just to give you
an example, Aviva
gave us access to
their entire CRM data.
And we are only the
second organization
in the world to have access to
their price elasticity data.
And that means we know the
connection, the relationship
between the digital
traffic for an individual,
their relative price elasticity,
and anything else Aviva
knows about the individual.
So the application
data, for example,
that when you sign on
for an insurance quote,
we fuse that data
together, applied a machine
learning technique, and
then pushed that result
to DoubleClick.
We're steadily rolling
this out for a number
of our global
clients, which means
we need a cloud partner that
will scale with us in this way.
In this particular example,
the volumes of data
aren't particularly huge.
We're talking about between
50 and 100 gigabytes a day.
So it's not enormous.
But the point is this is
for every single client.
This is not one use
case for one client.
This is all our
major global clients.
So as we move
forward, that score
that we're generating
through machine learning
is now a very rich picture of
what we know about that cookie.
It's what we call a smart ID.
So that means that the factors
that we're passing back
to DoubleClick are
a very rich picture
of what role has content,
for example, played
in the conversion.
What role has an
individual campaign
played in its conversion?
And we're starting to
unpick content, for example,
so assigning numerical values
to text, video, and graphics.
Because we want to
understand, what
is it that's really
driven the conversion?
Now I'm slightly heretical
in my organization,
and I don't believe that media
always drives the conversion.
It absolutely doesn't.
There are many other factors
that drive a conversion.
And what we're
starting to unpick here
is what is the
relationship between some
of those other factors.
And this is the primary
use case that we've
applied Google Cloud.
In terms of performance,
just to give you
some idea of scale in
that Aviva example,
this is transformational stuff.
We identified 83,000 additional
quotes in our initial exercise
in the first three months.
And if you were to sum
this up over the course
of the relationship with Aviva
just on this single project,
a 15% reduction in CPA, which
for them is very significant.
And they're the first
insurance organization
to even attempt this.
So just in terms of
specifically wrapping up
on the benefits of
GCP for us, we've
seen a 30% reduction in
the client setup process--
which for us is
fairly significant,
because use of talent
is a challenge--
a 20% reduction in hardware
resource for machine learning
solutions, and a 20% reduction
in computation costs.
Which for us, given
the scale of what
we're trying to do
across something
like 150 global clients, this
is really quite significant.
But probably the important thing
is, just to close, is I say
Google as the partner,
not a software supplier.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: Thank you.
Next up I would like to
introduce Damian Lawlor, who
will help rap us up.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Thank you Matt.
That's machine
learning in action.
So you probably can guess
from my accent that I'm Irish.
And I actually love
collecting pithy quotes.
So to share, I loved that "was
the juice worth the squeeze."
I'm delighted to hear that
it actually was as well.
But I'm going to
remember that one.
So I'm really just going
to run very quickly
through what Matt said.
This is all about accelerating
your time to insight.
We recognize that time
and the speed of response
is becoming more and
more important in terms
of being able to
use your customer
data or your customers'
customers' data.
Every single piece
of data you can get,
the faster you can combine
all of those data silos
together and drive insight,
then the faster you're
going to differentiate
yourself and really
drive long term sustainable
competitive advantage.
Our goal is to help
you along that path.
That's why we announced today
the BigQuery Data Transfer
Service.
There are some great stories
about how people have actually
been able to use that to
assist, to make life easier,
to be able to take
advantage of us building
these connectors for you
rather than you having
to do this for yourselves.
And then combine
that, we recognize,
we actually want to
keep working at this
and adding more and more
connectivity to more
and more data sources,
making it as easy as
possible to break down that
huge problem we all have of data
silos.
Because if we can get
all that data together,
we can unlock very,
very rich value.
And then Matt walked
through the three steps
in terms of getting insight--
being able to use Cloud
Dataprep, Cloud Dataflow,
and to get clean
data into BigQuery.
We know that this is a
really, really big investment
step for many, many people
right after the ability
to collect as many data
sources as possible--
and then analyze and visualize.
That's not where
we want to stop.
This is really
just the beginning
of what we're going
to be announcing
over the next
months, because what
we want to continually
to do is bring out
solutions that make
things as easy as possible
for you to engage
with cloud computing
and really get marketing
analytics in the cloud working
for you.
So over the next
couple of months,
you'll see us bringing out
packages of solutions that
will enable you to consume cloud
in as simple a way as possible,
so a package that will include
BigQuery Compute, BigQuery
Storage, Dataprep, and various
other parts of the cloud
platform in a way that will
allow you and your teams
to start really being able to
expand the amount of querying
you can do exponentially
from where you might be now.
Because our goal is
that if we can give you,
for example, a fixed price
for unlimited querying
on a monthly basis or
on an annual basis,
we believe that
will really unlock
the creativity of your teams.
So I think please
do come and talk
to us about the BigQuery Data
Transfer Service, which was
announced today, and Dataprep.
And in the coming weeks
you will hear more and more
from us in terms
of other solutions
that we're bringing
you that we'd
love you to directly engage with
us, and we can talk it through.
And in fact we'd
like to show you it
because showing is much
more powerful than telling.
I think anyone who was at
the 12 o'clock presentation
and saw how fast
that petabyte got
queried, that's more impressive
than me telling me about it.
What I'd like to do now is to
get another two of our partners
to come up and share
some more stories
and just talk us through what
their experience has been
to date in working with
cloud, and in specifically
in working with Google Cloud.
So an Allan Beaufour,
Senior Vice President
of Engineering from "The New
York Times," and Peter Jaffe,
the Data Lead from
Hearst, are going
to join me for a fireside chat.
But it's California, so
it's without the fire.
So we're all got microphones.
I'd like to start by
saying, we're at Next,
so a lot of today was
based around what's
coming in the future.
But if you don't mind, I'd
really love if both of you
would actually talk us through
your route into the cloud.
What were you hoping to achieve
in that route, in that road
into cloud computing?
And then the follow
up question is
going to be, where do you
think you are against achieving
those original goals yet?
Maybe Allan, if
you want to start.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: Sire.
What do we hope to do--
a lot of different things.
We had a mix of AWS and a lot
of not very well maintained data
stores, which probably is
common among a lot of us.
We had Redshift.
We have on-premise Hadoop.
I know who had that idea.
We wanted to collect a lot of
that, put it in one, you know,
this data lake
concept, put it online,
make all data join away.
Where we are now,
we've killed Redshift.
We've shut down Hadoop.
We have a fair amount
of data in BigQuery.
It's up and running.
We're Dataflow.
We're using Pub/Sub.
And BigQuery is driving a lot
of our analysis, not all of it
yet.
We still have data
sets to be moved.
One of the things, we're
not in the business
of running infrastructure.
We were to some extent.
I want to get away from that.
We want to publish content,
write content, distribute it.
So some of the things that
drove us to Google Cloud
in particular was the no
ops attributes of BigQuery.
Redshift needs some ops.
We didn't do that very well.
BigQuery needs no ops.
So far, it's working out
really, really well for us.
And we don't need any people
thinking about operations,
which is amazing.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Peter?
PETER JAFFE: So
Hearst in general,
enterprise technology a
few years ago decided,
as a general initiative, to try
to move as much as they could
into the cloud and
away from on-premise.
And they'd been doing that
because of the efficiencies
and the ease of
use and how easy it
is to add resources
and things like that.
And in general they've been
very successful with that.
Our specific group, the data
engineering and data science
group, was only
born four years ago.
And so we've been entirely
on cloud since the beginning.
And that was initially all AWS.
And similar to
Allan's story, we've
been migrating over to Google
Cloud over the last year
initially because of
BigQuery and how fast it is
and how cost effective for our
use case compared to Redshift.
We have a bunch of
Redshift clusters.
We used to have more.
And they're really big and
they're really expensive.
And it's been very
successful for us
to be moving over
to BigQuery where
we can have a lot more data
available for immediate
querying at a much
lower cost compared
to what it would be to have
all of that stuff in Redshift.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: In terms
of the move to cloud,
is starting with the data and
analytics platform on cloud,
is that a good place
to start for somebody
who is maybe thinking
about the journey to cloud?
PETER JAFFE: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it's been some
years since I did analytics
on data sets that
were on-premise.
And it's just very
liberating, as the person
who's interacting with the
data, to have it on the cloud,
because it's so easy to spin
up additional resources,
to move data around, to
get data into the database
where you're going to
perform your analysis.
It's so easy to put Tableau
or Looker on top of that.
I can't imagine, at this
point, doing it any other way.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR:
Data is really where
you need elasticity and growth.
We're not going to get less
data in the world, right?
It's only going to come more.
It's going to be more
and more prevalent.
And whatever business
function you're running,
there will be more data.
And doing that on-premise,
you'll be provisioning for now
and forever.
So yeah, I would say it's
a good place to start.
You need it.
DAMIAN LAWLOR:
And I remember you
telling a story in New
York about how actually it
was the data
analytics that spurred
some thoughts about
other workloads
then moving over to the cloud.
Can you tell us a bit
more about that journey?
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: Yeah.
So before BigQuery,
or rather I would say
BigQuery has really transformed
how a lot of analysts
do their work, because
they do the same work
but BigQuery has enabled
them to kind of stay
in this inquisitive, asking
the data questions mindset.
Whereas before, they kind
of came up with a theory,
did a query in either
Redshift or Hive,
and then went to lunch,
or went to a meeting,
and then came back and oh, what
if I ask this question instead
or this and this and this?
Right now it's a much
more interactive session
with BigQuery, which
has really unleashed
a lot of analytics and
thinking and creativity,
where they can query the
data, see something, come
back, create another
way, add more filters.
It's a much more fluid
workload instead of context
switching all the time.
You do this, go to
lunch, come back.
Oh, what was I doing?
So it's really opened up
so many more things for us
to have a much more interactive
session with the data.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Just a quick
question to the audience.
How many in the audience are
already doing data analytics
in the cloud?
OK, so then I think this
next question is relevant.
So for those that aren't,
what are the pitfalls
that you think people
should think through
as they start this journey?
Peter, if you want to--
PETER JAFFE: Pitfalls to moving
your data into the cloud we're
talking about-- yeah.
Well, gee, that's a tough one.
I mean, there are
so many advantages
to moving to the cloud.
I think that if you've got
a lot of infrastructure
on top of your on-premise
data, you've got a lot of stuff
to migrate, getting buy-in,
getting people on board,
figuring out what tools
you're going to use.
My experience with data sets
that were all on-premise
was that the tools on top
of them were not that great.
It was a lot harder
to get insights out.
And maybe the specific tools
that are responsible for that.
But I don't think that aside
from getting your organization
behind it, that
there is a lot of--
there's not a lot of danger.
I think that people
are more afraid
that there's going
to be security gaps
and things like that.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: I don't
know, like it's the same.
I don't know if there
are any big pitfalls.
There are some challenges,
making sure your security
department, your
infosec department
understands what it's about.
And it's hard doing
data center security,
but Google actually
has a lot of people
that know how to do that, that
it's hard to compete with.
It is easier to burn
through some money,
if you're not careful.
Like if you have
provisioned hardware
you paid for, you're not
burning any more money there.
So you can do some missteps
and burned through the money,
but set up some quotas
and that stops there.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: OK.
So you didn't-- one of the
things I hear from other people
who are looking at this is how
difficult it can be to break
down the data silos or
actually get individual areas
of their business to
cough up the data,
if we can put it like that.
Was that an issue for
either of you, in terms of--
PETER JAFFE: That has not
been an issue at Hearst.
I mean I would say the
opposite, that everybody
wants to have their data
in a central location.
And maybe this is organization
specific at Hearst,
but we have a lot of use
across the organization
with our common data set.
And in fact this has been
great in Google Cloud
in particular versus what
we are experiencing in AWS.
It's just been so easy
to provision users
and give them access
to different data sets,
and not just data
sets in BigQuery,
but other resources within the
cloud like Compute and Storage
and whatever else
you might want.
We have had such great
adoption this year,
it's amazing to me how
many different people
from different businesses across
the organization at Hearst
are using our data that we've
been wanting them to use
for years, and they've
been wanting to use,
but it's just been harder
for them to get at it.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR:
Yeah, I think once
people-- we haven't
had too much trouble.
There are some old
flaky systems that
are a little hard to
get the data out of,
but it's not because people
have been actively resisting.
But we were talking about that
just before, like once people--
you shouldn't
underestimate the benefit
of having that Google Login and
a web UI on top of BigQuery.
Like it sounds silly that that's
an enabler, but it really is.
And once people see they
can just click a link,
they're already logged in.
Here's a SQL interface.
And they see the speed
and the ease of it,
getting to the data,
people are more than
happy to get their data
in there because they
can see what that enables.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: In
terms of enabling,
we had an interesting
conversation earlier on today
in terms of this concept of
a democratization of data
science, so the concept that
these tools were actually
go into allow access to
data to a much broader group
within the organization, and
that would unleash creativity
within your organization.
Is that something you're
seeing or you believe in?
Where are we on that?
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: So, yes and no.
As I think also
said earlier, like
after the initial
excitement, there's
usually some frustration
that follows quickly after.
Just having access to the data
doesn't mean you understand it.
So you can give all
the self-service access
to the data you want and people
poke around in it and then
come up with reports that
don't make a lot of sense,
and then reconciliation
nightmare afterwards.
So I 100% believe
in that data should
be accessible to everyone,
regulation allowing,
because it does open up.
But that it just makes data
self-service and everyone
across the company
will just dig into it
and create their own
reports or data science,
yeah, I don't really see
that working out in practice.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Anything
different in Hearst?
PETER JAFFE: No,
I would generally
agree with everything
Allan said.
There are some
products coming out now
that are trying to get at that.
And with the data transfer
from like DFP into BigQuery--
Looker's just been
experimenting with this thing
they call blocks which is like
these ready made dashboards
that you can plug in
on top of your DFP
that has been imported
through the data transfer tool
into your BigQuery.
And a couple of
people at Hearst have
been playing around with that
and it looks kind of promising.
So I think that maybe we'll
get in that direction more.
But I generally completely
agree that opening it up
to people who were not
inclined to analyze the data
is not going to get them
to analyze the data.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Some
of the case studies
we've heard from
earlier, they talked
about how the benefits,
the actual business
outcomes that they were
able to drive from this move
to cloud data and analytics.
Are you comfortable to share
any of the transformations
or any of the positive
impacts that you've
had in your own organizations?
PETER JAFFE: I can talk about
specific products and things
that we've built on that.
I mean, we take our click
data and pull it off
of our 180 odd websites and
put it through a pipeline
and grab the impressions
that come back from DFP.
And I've got a real time
revenue estimation tool
that is built on top of that.
So I'm pulling in all
the clicks and I'm
pulling in the impressions
and I'm merging that together
and I'm estimating how much
revenue is being generated.
I'm pushing that out
to a tool that, it's
got a dashboard on top of it
that our traffic buyers use
to see high performing CPMs.
And they look for opportunities
to buy traffic at lower CPMs
and push it to those
URLs that are currently
earning high CPMs.
So that's a nice
example, I think,
of real world revenue being
driven off of the data.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Thank you.
Allan?
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: We're a little
further behind than that
in our--
it's more exploration
right now, more [INAUDIBLE]
enabled, more data
sets in BigQuery
that we can join
together has enabled more
exploratory analysis for us.
For example, in advertising,
getting DFP data out
and our click traffic in there
and exploring other advertising
scenarios and how that would
actually affect our revenue.
But we're not where we
actually build product.
We've migrated products,
data products into BigQuery,
but we haven't
built any new ones.
So I have no fancy things yet.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Well I think that
leads into my next question,
which is, what's next?
So where do you see--
what are you looking
forward to building out
over the next 12 to 18 months?
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: Oh, a lot.
More data sets, obviously--
the more data we
can get in and make
it a join away,
and then clean up all the
data quality issues that
will come out of seeing
the data together.
No, for me, there's a
couple of key things--
building data
products, but getting
the funnel of from a prototype
on a data scientist's
laptop to a data product
running in production,
getting that streamlined.
So really empowering
our data science team
to do all their crazy stuff with
R, Python notebooks, whatever,
and then putting the
machinery and the platform
together underneath
that makes it very easy
for them to run that
in production and feed
into, whether they put
stuff into BigQuery
or feed to our product
or whatever it is.
There's a lot of commonalities
between all data products.
And getting that up so we
can really empower the data
scientists, it's really
something I really, really
look forward to.
And then part of that is closing
kind of the feedback loop.
A lot of what we've been
striving with Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, BigQuery--
maybe not BigQuery in
that sense actually.
But it's streaming, have
most of our data streaming.
I want more streaming
data sets in there
so we can do real time models
that feed into the product,
change the product behavior,
then see the user actions
flow back into that and close
that feedback loop in many more
ways.
That's what I'm really,
really excited to see.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: So going
back to the comment that
was there earlier
about activation being
a really important
outcome of this,
that we want to move past just
analysis to actually automate
the outcomes and then use those
outcomes to drive the product.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR: In real time.
And right now, from a click
hits our website to it's
available for querying in
BigQuery, it's 45 seconds.
So that's pretty fast.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: And Peter?
PETER JAFFE: Yeah, we have
[INAUDIBLE] an experience.
Our click into BigQuery
is also under a minute.
It's pretty fast.
Similar, we have more data
sets that we want to bring in.
And because the technology's
evolving so quickly
in this space, we keep iterating
on how our pipelines work
and making them
better and better.
And I think right now, we're
interested in incorporating
Dataflow and some other products
like that that we're not really
using yet, and just trying
to make our pipeline faster
and more robust.
It's fast and robust, but it can
also be faster and more robust.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: And maybe as
a final question from me,
you mentioned that technology
is evolving very quickly.
Where are you
hoping it evolves to
over the next 12 to 18 months?
What would the evolution
be that would add the most
value for your businesses
and the business outcomes
you're looking to achieve?
No pressure.
PETER JAFFE: That's tough.
I mean, just make everything
easier and better.
[LAUGHTER]
DAMIAN LAWLOR: We do have
a few product managers
and engineers in the audience.
ALLAN BEAUFOUR:
Just like BigQuery
is like no ops, like
more of those tools,
like fully get away
from spinning up
servers or instances or
containers or whatever it is.
The more no op tools I can
put in there, the better.
I was pretty happy.
I can't remember the name of
it, but the PII detection tool
you guys launched, getting
that stuff in there
like automatic detecting
PII, regulatory things that
aren't as they should,
the more integration I
can get between all those
products in a no opsy way,
that's amazing.
I'm pretty happy
to see Dataprep.
But we were talking
about earlier,
Dataprep is one end of the scale
and Dataflow is the other end.
And the somewhere
in between, I'm
looking for something
there that is not
the heavy hand of Dataflow, not
the somewhat simple Dataprep,
but the in between,
that I'm looking forward
for in a no opsy way.
DAMIAN LAWLOR: OK, so I'd like
to close off the fireside.
So just a thank you very,
very much to Allan and Peter.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]